opportunity opportunity opportunity
opportunities opportunities I want and
created opportunity for myself
hello believe nation my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe the entrepreneurs are going to
solve all of the world's major problems
so to help you in your journey today
we're going to learn how you cannot miss
opportunities and as always as you're
watching if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down in the comments below and put
quotes around it to other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick with yourself
as well joy
[Music]
many of you have a very small
opportunity and you're not taking
advantage of that opportunity because
you're not thinking about the next
opportunist and small no this is the
gateway like just the first one right so
you got to ask yourself this question
like how do you keep that fire you know
how you keep it you keep putting
different opportunities in front you
keep setting different opportunities
anybody know who this is you sure here
in the big kid he gave us the business
you should know he is yogi Ferrell
didn't get drafted didn't get dr2 to the
NBA didn't get drafted but they just
something happened the other day to
Dallas Mavericks me to the player they
gave my man a 10-day contract did he
make he'll know how much LeBron makes it
a million they are my men look for 10
days you just want you to play for
somebody got hurt we are gonna bring you
in for 10 days so you got 10 days ride
the [ __ ] you know do your thing but you
only got 10 days don't get your hopes up
my man then coming in it I'm talking
about schrick boom not only
three-pointers like daggers 2 seconds
boom the 10-day contract and turn it is
buoyed by to get a contract what are you
doing with your opportunities you all
get one we all get the 10-day contract
but the question is what that 10-day
contract son into a gear contract well
they turn into a two-year contract you
think yogi Pharaohs the only one who's
got the opportunity to come from a
developmental vegan place nope you think
other people doing Lee doing no why
because they weren't prepared for what
are you doing in the dark
when nobody watch it what are you doing
in the dark
10-day contract but he didn't come in
and say I only got 10 days that's what
some of y'all roll
oh there's only got 10 days I might only
give 10 days work for effort I'm out
we're only here 10 days worth the energy
Yogi Berra was like I'm about to act
like this might be my last shot I'm
going to act like I'm starting I'm not
acting like LeBron how about to act like
Kyrie
how about act like Shepard when you put
me in the game I'm telling you about the
murder room and exit index keep in
murdering him even though he is here
almost every game all
talk about yoga fair I'm talking about
NBA TV ESPN or espn2 cystatin EDS me so
y'all gotta understand town what was
your what was y'all be doing before what
was joking through before he got that
opportunity all he was preparing for
word you don't get him a game and score
like he's gone so he said so what I
didn't make the league so what they came
taught me from practicing they came Safi
from getting up in the morning and
running drills so the problem with most
of humans you have an opportunity you
wrote it down you wrote it down right
here opportunity they gave me an
opportunity they gave me a shot somebody
gave me a GE I turned that gene into a
four-year degree somebody gave me a boy
your degree I turned into a master's
degree somebody getting your master's
degree I turned into a PhD you got the
opportunity what you're doing with it
opportunity is government will you'll be
writing when it comes what if I offered
you 1.25 million dollars to sell the
whole companies mark you're saying screw
the other sharks yep I like what you
guys are doing I want you to come back
to me with a percentage I don't want you
to even talk to these guys you're asking
him to take that option with you right
now and of Nora you're not a very nice
guy thought about B being wonderful no
no I have that title thinking about
making a business decision right hi I'm
Mark Cuban I'm a bully look at me
what's a turd am what like I said guys
you got to pay to play attention in this
room I can do it it's offensive you got
a shot here right don't let these guys
drag you down are you really interested
in I like the idea you really think
cooking bacon bedside is a good idea I
love your passion I love your knowledge
waiting for the bite yeah there's a but
coming
you've got a 24-second shot clock
$750,000 I've never seen grade like that
that's unbelievable great you broke up
with your potential partner without even
looking at them you're a savage just a
lean mean sharp machine baby
I say yes to whatever your counter is
you have to tell me that you will say
yes immediately and we have a deal
$100,000 wait a minute for 20% equity
gone Donna done do you like that Barbara
I don't like it one did that's a
compliment to you Barbara I screwed you
but it's a compliment to you
for every problem the problem itself
presents an opportunity that Dwarfs the
problem and that is to say that if I had
only looked at my failure with the audio
book and you did as a failure in the
product let's say and not in the process
I wouldn't have taken away much instead
I realized that my approach wasn't right
fixed my a person that has led to a lot
of great successes success he's gone out
of luck its awareness of mind that takes
advantage of that opportunity
you will all be confronted with
opportunity
you must take advantage of it because if
you don't take advantage of your
opportunity you will never realize your
dreams
whether you want them or not is
irrelevant you don't know that until you
achieve it I grew up watching movies and
imagining myself on screen so aside from
the very serious things that I do I will
occasionally do snakes on a plane
because those were the kind of movies I
like when I was a kid I always wanted to
see myself in a movie with a bunch of
snakes and I'm I'm still trying to find
the right you know slasher movie to do
because I like slasher movies and I'm
still you know I did things like deep
blue sea because I wanted to run from
something that had big teeth and
hologram so I'm not that serious about
it you know I really think movies should
be fun and I think they should be
entertaining if I want to teach you
something I'll do documentary but I do
this because it feeds me it feeds my
artistic sense a lot of people think I
do too many movies I read an article in
paper yesterday about me doing too many
movies but you know writers get up and
write every day
painters get up and paint every day
actors only have so many acting
opportunities in a lifetime I'm going to
take mine as they come and do as many
movies as I can before them about it
here I remember two years ago when the
two silver offer me play the Levi guy
villain you need 11 floors I say oh I
made the 25 movies in Hong Kong I never
play the villain so I don't know my
audience
what's their reaction when they heard of
the news so is it don't worry here is a
good guy he offered not always roaming
much guy so when one by guy when good
guy you can work you have a special
skill you can make money for the studio
than in the future right now maybe
tighter than before I have a little bit
chance could can choose what kind of
story I really want to make it I hope in
the future I have more chance and truth
what kind of story I really want to make
what kind of story I don't want to make
we had only been there 32 I think we
hadn't done even 50 show Wow
and so I called John Stuart and I said
John I just got invited you know for the
Correspondents Dinner
do you think I should do it and he said
what like to attend and I said no they
want me because they want you to be the
guy is like I stand next to the
president do they know what you do I
said I don't know and I said I think I
have to do which is you have to do it
you like how are you now you have to do
it so don't pay attention to the
approval ratings that say that 68
percent of Americans disapprove of the
job this man is doing I ask you this
does that not also logically mean that
68% approve of the job he's not doing
think about it I haven't you know each
day looks very very different and
truthfully that's part of what I'm I'm
so passionate about I think more than
being a developer more than having my
own fashion brand I think of myself as
an entrepreneur who keeps my eye open
for exciting opportunities and and you
have to have bandwidth in your schedule
despite how busy you are you have to
have a little bit of space to be able to
take that meeting that's not as
strategically relevant to everything on
your plate so it is important to be
surrounded by by people that you trust
and and it's important to spend your
time wisely to enable you to the
climatic stop
I used to do make the perfect for my
stuff they were very bad but I was the
only one doing them so a lot of friends
when I was doing my short films they
would see the effect and see who did
that for it I say I did it and they
started telling me would you do mine
and I started doing it and I realized it
was an edge with which going to feature
films and what I did is for example and
we did a TV series called all America
was just again terrible filmmaking but
we were all learning Alfonso Cuaron was
there I was there Emmanuel Lubezki the
Deepika German evarro my VP always
started in that series and we were doing
little experiments and I would I said to
the producers I'll do the makeup effects
for free you pay the materials I do them
for free but in exchange I write and
direct episodes and they said that's a
good deal so it was a way to put your
foot on the door and I and I was already
on the way to the Khronos I started
winding Kronos around 1985 and I knew
that in order to make the device the
Kronos device and the neck up effect I
needed to create a company that would
tell the producers there's someone that
can do those effects so the sooner I did
Kronos essentially a year later the shop
was closed because it has served its
purpose there's a bunch of cats who like
I get it they look at it like it's
stupid why would you waste your
opportunities or something they don't
seem to think that this is something
given by others like they still see it
as like you've been given an opportunity
no he gave me Jack I want and created an
opportunity for myself nobody ever shows
up at your door knocks and says hey man
you want to tell stories much money go
make-pretend I've never done that that
doesn't happen
you gotta make steps toward that thing
in the first place so I spent a lot of
time trying to explain to people the
difference between like you know given
an opportunity and creating your world
creating your own opportunity because if
you create your own opportunities we
hold nobody then people can't say things
like you shouldn't do this like why so
long as I keep my budget slow make sure
everyone gets their money back and stuff
I can do whatever goofy thing I want to
say right now I want
go to my grave one day being like I
should have made the walrus movie and
then drop gonna be to God it's like
can't believe we made that wall and I'm
dropped by the yellow but satisfied
because we're not talking about
reshaping the world or big important
issues that is all micro not macro and
stuff it all begins kind of with you so
you know that's about belief you can't
expect a bunch of people out there to
believe you are this thing unless you be
this thing yourself thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed I'd
love to know what did you take from this
video that you are going to immediately
now apply to your life or your business
somehow please leave it down the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to Trident Lion thank you so
much you're picking up a copy of my book
your WOD word and we're reading it and
doing a review on your YouTube channel
I really really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the
book today this video is all about your
one word thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon